y volvemos a hablar de economía en
directo América con nuestro periodista
Daniela Blandón Daniela bienvenida de
nuevo Cómo está muy bien María Clara
llena de noticias Bueno entonces
empecemos con las noticias de Europa
Cuál es la situación delgadas en el
viejo continente Bueno lo hemos venido
mencionando durante las últimas semanas
Si es que muchos países europeos se han
apretado el cinturón a medida que se
disparan los costos de la energía y de
cara al próximo invierno la compañía
energética Estatal de Rusia mantiene
cerrado el gasoducto North extremo 1 que
lleva gas a Europa por el mar Báltico el
kremlin dice que tiene una falla técnica
que tiene que ser solucionada por la
multinacional siemens pero Alemania y
sus aliados occidentales lo ven como un
juego de poder político Italia anunció
Este martes un plan de ahorro según el
cual va a reducir la temperatura de la
calefacción en hogares y negocios
durante el invierno a 19 grados Celsius
como máximo un grado menos que antes y
Portugal acaba de lanzar un paquete de
ayudas por 2 400 millones de euros para
sus ciudadanos escuchemos de qué se
trata
atribuir un seguimiento extraordinario
el gobierno ha decidido conceder una
ayuda extraordinaria de 125 euros a
todos ciudadano trabajador cuyos
ingresos no superen los 2700 euros
mensuales los pensionados recibirán un
apoyo extraordinario equivalente a medio
mes de pensión esta medida equivale a
más del 50% del valor normal de la
pensión y se pagará una sola vez en
octubre también hemos decidido proponer
a la asamblea nacional una reducción al
6% del impuesto habitual del 13% sobre
la electricidad
difícil la situación de los europeos en
este momento Daniela pasemos a Estados
Unidos porque Joe biden defendió a los
empleados en el día del trabajo Sí
señora la luna se conmemoró este día del
trabajo en Estados Unidos y el
presidente participó en eventos
sindicales en dos estados clave para las
elecciones de noviembre que renuevan el
congreso que son y Pensilvania Allí se
mostró como el mayor defensor de los
trabajadores
estoy aquí por ustedes la clase media
construyó Estados Unidos todo el mundo
lo sabe Pero los sindicatos construyeron
la clase media eso es un hecho
[Aplausos]
yo no estaría aquí sin sindicatos
electricistas herreros carteros
camioneros albañiles obreros
trabajadores del tránsito plomero
trabajadores hidráulicos yo no estaría
aquí sin policía sin bomberos maestros o
enfermeras
bueno y sus palabras se dan en momentos
en que Estados Unidos vive un
importantísimo momento sindical que tomó
fuerza después de la pandemia Y es que
miles de trabajadores de grandes
compañías como Starbucks o Amazon están
intentando sindicalizarse frente a la
oposición de sus empleadores esto como
una manera de reclamar derechos que
alegan les fueron vulnerados durante la
pandemia bueno Daniela y ahora una
pregunta personal le gusta la piña me
encanta la piña en todas sus expresiones
le cuento que la piña costarricense ya
está en Israel qué más detalles tienen
Esto bueno cómo le parece además Costa
Rica es uno de los principales
exportadores mundiales de piña con
ventas anuales que rondan los 900
millones de dólares Pues esta semana la
empresa costarricense upala agrícola
realizó el primer envío de un cargamento
de piña desde el país centroamericano
hacia Israel luego de cumplir con una
serie de requisitos fitosanitarios y
también de calidad lo anunciaron en un
evento conjunto entre altos funcionarios
de ambos países durante una visita que
hizo el ministro de comercio exterior de
Costa Rica Manuel Tovar a esa nación
bueno Daniela y cuáles son los
indicadores del día bueno pues tenemos
en Europa ponemos el foco en Londres
cuyo principal índice de 100 apenas
muestra cambios al alza en medio del
juramento del estrés como nueva ministra
o nueva primera ministra conservadora
del Reino Unido aunque no se han dado a
conocer planes muy para hacer frente a
la creciente inflación lo que sí ha
surgido Es que la bbc de Londres informó
que otros planea congelar las facturas
de energía de los hogares por los
próximos 18 meses y en el Asia Pacífico
los mercados cerraron mixtos con
Australia a la baja después de que el
Banco Central elevara su tasa de interés
por quinto mes consecutivo hasta
ubicarse en un máximo de siete años
bueno Daniela y cuál es la cifra del día
pero que sea una cifra alcanzable para
nosotros los seres terrenales no es
alcanzable para nosotros los seres
terrenales pero igual se la voy a decir
entre 60.000 y 85 mil millones de
dólares eso es lo que los inversionistas
han calculado que cuesta la salida a
bolsa de Porsche Volkswagen que es la
casa matriz de esta marca de autos
deportivos de lujo Calcula que incluso
antes de finalizar este año Porsche se
enlistaría en Europa en una de las más
grandes ofertas públicas de este año
inclusive a pesar de la turbulencia del
mercado está lista para comprarlo pero
súper lista para comprar por lo menos
las acciones Bueno al menos gracias por
la información económica nos vemos
mañana con más información y nosotros
seguimos con directo París